Russia says one child was killed and 20
civilians injured in the shelling of the
town of volno Vaca south of Donetsk
local Russian installed officials say
that it was shelled by six to ten high
Mars Rockets this happened in the early
hours of Monday Kiev has not commented
on the situation the town is about 26
kilometers away from the front line in
the russian-controlled part of the
Donetsk region the nearest Ukrainian
Hill town of vuladar has seen heavy
fighting in the past six months Vol
novaco was taken by Russian forces last
year well our correspondent Ali Hashem
is in vulnavaka Ukraine Ali share with
us what you've seen
thank you
cereal we are in volubaka as you said
there are several areas in this city or
this town that were targeted this
morning as per Russian sources this is
one this is a boss this used to be a bus
stop so it was hit with one of the
missiles also there are several other
locations that we went to some of them
are closed because of security measures
this is one of the areas that we were
allowed to take some footage this is
also one of the business centers that
also was hit as we understood that there
are around 22 23 people who were injured
amongst them two in a severe condition
however this is not the first time this
town is being targeted over the the road
from juniesk to uh which is like 70
kilometers away
we can see many destroyed home as many
destroyed shops centers city is more of
a big buttocks with a lot of of soldiers
in it and it's by the way the midpoint
between junior and maripol so we took
all the way to come to the city in order
to check on what happened it seems the
several targets that were hit some of
them as we understood from local sources
our areas where AID is being distributed
to people but since the the area was
targeted the number of injuries as we
said went to 22 at least and three or
two sorry were in critical situation Ali
Hashem thank you very much for reporting
in the Donetsk region appreciate your
reporting thank you